[Musik]
hier sind die ganzen daten
wer zum beispiel wann was gegründet hat
so fand nicht auffallen weil ich möchte
erst gar nicht ganz da muss doch weiter
hier steht ganz klar dass die afg als
auffangnetz von niemand geringeren als
von frau merkel selber gegründet worden
ist als aufwand partei für den fall dass
die cdu oder csu ins rutschen kommen
damit wir weiter an der spitze platz ist
ein knüller
ja das ist aber das ist ja besser als
hitler tagebücher des stern hier steht
im dings ganz knallhart drin stehe ich
hier einmal so wir mitten rein
die erklärten ziele der afg gründung
kritische und besorgte bürger sollen in
einer partei gebündelt werden
die vollen unter kontrolle von merkel &
co steht und nun staunt man § 23 im
falle einer planmäßigen auflösung
gezeichnet berlin sechster februar 2013
angela merkel
der wagen kommt gleich wir müssen uns
ein bisschen daran halten unser zug aber
sehr gut dass sie das vorgelesen habe